Katrina: 哈哈哈哎这你别说还真藏了一个
Katrina: Hahaha, oh wow, you actually hid one here.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 这怎么还在这
Lucia: How is this still here?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Katrina: 完了全被 找
Katrina: Oh no, they found them all.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Katrina: 你可以找一下那个我们藏的贴纸
Katrina: You can try looking for the stickers we hid.
Jake:然后那个相机都不能动
Jake: And the cameras can't be moved.
Jake:别的都欢迎大家随便动
Jake: Everything else, feel free to touch.
Alice:没事你已经找到3个了
Alice: It's okay, you've already found three.
Alice:已经很牛了
Alice: That's pretty impressive.
Jake:每个相机都不能动
Jake: Each camera can't be moved.
其他人：检查下袋子
Others: Check the bags.
其他人：万一有垃圾袋
Others: Just in case there's a trash bag.
Katrina: 找找找找
Katrina: Look, look, look.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina: 我想想就是这些地方都可以找
Katrina: I think you can search all these places.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：不会真在厕所里藏着吧
Others: Could it really be hidden in the bathroom?
Katrina: （歌声）没有你在我又冷
Katrina: (Singing) Without you here, I'm cold again.
Alice:啊手套到了
Alice: Ah, the gloves are here.
Katrina: 这是我们那个软件
Katrina: This is our software.
Katrina: 就是开始录制然后他就会那个
Katrina: We start recording and then it...
Katrina: 找一下吧
Katrina: Let's look for it.
Katrina: 我也不知道我藏哪了
Katrina: I don't even know where I hid it.
Katrina: 我就藏了一个
Katrina: I just hid one.
Katrina: 其他的都是他们藏
Katrina: The others hid the rest.
Katrina: 你看这里哈哈哈
Katrina: Look here, hahaha.
其他人：这么明显一个
Others: It's so obvious.
其他人：这么半天看不见
Others: How could you not see it for so long?
Katrina: 这么半天看不见在哪这呢
Katrina: You couldn't see it for so long, it's right here.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 哪
Katrina: Where?
Katrina: 嗯嗯对就是这种贴纸
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, it's this kind of sticker.
Katrina: 有意思
Katrina: Interesting.
Alice:没事你找到3个了已经不错了
Alice: It's okay, you found three, that's not bad.
Alice:可以给其他嘉宾留点
Alice: Leave some for the other guests.
Alice:一共20个
Alice: There are twenty in total.
Katrina: 外面外面有藏吗昨天
Katrina: Were there any hidden outside yesterday?
其他人：男女分开
Others: Boys and girls separate.
其他人：楼上楼下
Others: Upstairs and downstairs
Katrina: 没有男女分开
Katrina: No separation of genders
Katrina: 是我们是四女两男嘛
Katrina: Yeah, we have four girls and two guys
Katrina: 然后一个男生
Katrina: And one guy
Katrina: 哈喽一个男生是他志愿者
Katrina: Hello, one of the guys is a volunteer
Alice:都是花钱堆出来的
Alice: All bought with money
Katrina: 还有一个就是我们立的
Katrina: And the other one is our own
Alice:你敢信吗
Alice: Can you believe it?
Katrina: 就是他自己当志愿者采集数据
Katrina: He volunteers to collect data himself
Katrina: 然后其他那两个男生是是来帮忙的
Katrina: And the other two guys are here to help
Katrina: 就是工作人员
Katrina: They're staff members
Katrina: 常务这个姐姐也是个常务
Katrina: And this sister is also a staff member
Katrina: 嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, just
Katrina: 智能体吧
Katrina: Intelligent body
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes
Katrina: 叫什么方向来着
Katrina: What's the direction again?
Katrina: 他们做的这个方向
其他人：这个项目的方向
Others: The direction of this project
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Right
Katrina: 对就是跟大模型有关
Katrina: Yes, it's related to the big model
Katrina: 然后就他们的数据集
Katrina: And their dataset
Katrina: 就是自己采的这种视频形式
Katrina: Is collected in this video format
Katrina: 他们组里有自己的那个模型
Katrina: They have their own model in the group
Katrina: 然后把这个输进去就行了
Katrina: And they just input it
Katrina: 走吧那应该是外面没有啊
Katrina: Let's go, it should be outside
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Lucia: 啊这是对的
Lucia: Ah, that's right
Katrina: 你看我今天做的那个压花很好看啊
Katrina: Look, the pressed flowers I made today are beautiful, right?
Katrina: 哦我等会还要给他打孔看
Katrina: Oh, I still need to punch holes later
Katrina: 你认得出这些花吗
Katrina: Can you recognize these flowers?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 这这个是康乃馨
Katrina: This one is a carnation
Katrina: 这个是那个芍药
Katrina: This one is a peony
Katrina: 芍药能开特别大
Katrina: Peonies can bloom really big
Katrina: 然后呢就把它这样压扁了
Katrina: And then we press them flat like this
Katrina: 其他的就是一些百合
Katrina: The rest are some lilies
其他人：楼上有人弹琴
Others: Someone's playing the piano upstairs
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah
Katrina: 你可以玩他们的琴和吉他
Katrina: You can play their piano and guitar
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:我觉得我像
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
其他人：哈哈哈汤姆猫里面的女主人
Others: Hahaha, like the lady from Tom and Jerry.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 再找找不
Katrina: Should we keep looking?
Alice:哈笑死
Alice: Haha, I'm dying.
其他人：旁边偷两
Others: Steal a couple from the side.
Katrina: 哈哈偷了也没人知哈哈
Katrina: Haha, no one will notice if we steal them, haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Alice:哈哈那有什么办法呢
Alice: Haha, what else can we do?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：第一视角大模型
Others: First-person big model.
Alice:没辙
Alice: No way.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Exactly, exactly.
Katrina: 他们后期会提问
Katrina: They'll ask questions later.
Katrina: 就是看这段视频
Katrina: Just watch this video.
Katrina: 就提问AI这个人现在在干什么
Katrina: And ask the AI what this person is doing now.
Katrina: 然后这个东西是从哪来的
Katrina: And where this thing came from.